[APPLAUSE]
OBI FELTEN: Right.
Well, hello everyone.
It's a real honor to be here.
I'm following Maryann Bruce,
which is pretty tough,
and I'm standing between you and
drinks, which is pretty tough,
too.
But I'll try and make the next
20 minutes interesting, OK?
So I work at X. We're the
team behind self-driving cars,
self-flying delivery vehicles,
smartglasses, smart contact
lenses, energy kites, and
internet from balloons.
We work on solving large
problems with technology.
But this talk isn't
about X. This talk
is about how to kill good
things-- a good idea,
a project, your company, or
your current job-- to make
room for truly great ones.
We don't like killing our own
projects, because it's hard.
And it's hard for two
reasons-- fear and inertia.
And to overcome these two
things that stand in your way,
you have to tackle them head-on.
And that's what my talk
is going to be about.
So let's start with inertia.
This is Newton's
first law of motion.
And as you know, as
a good physicist,
the bigger the mass and the
faster the object is moving,
the more force you have to apply
to stop it or divert its path.
Well, the rest of
life is just the same.
It's often much easier
for us to just keep going.
But the longer we keep
going with a project,
the higher is the
opportunity cost
if we eventually do kill it.
At X, we therefore try
to kill as many things as
possible as early as possible.
Our process starts with a
small team called Rapid Eval.
They are a team of polymath
scientists and prototypers,
and their job is
to create new ideas
and prototype them as
quickly as possible,
and figure out whether
they work or not.
And if they don't
work, they kill them.
I asked Rich, the guy who
runs our team, how many
of their ideas make it through.
And he said, oh, about 3%.
So about 3% of Rapid
Eval ideas make it
into the next stage,
which is Foundry.
And that's my team.
So we're a group of product
managers, of engineers,
of strategists, and we continue
to de-risk the technology,
but we also try and
find product market fit.
And we build business plans.
And we try and do
that within a year,
just like a startup would do.
And the goal of that year is
to either de-risk the project
to a point where we're
comfortable growing it,
and therefore graduate it
to become an independent X
project, or we kill it.
Now, you'll notice
on this chart that we
don't hire a manager
for the project
until it graduates from Foundry.
And that's deliberate.
Because often, the lead
is the last person who
wants to kill their project.
The chart also illustrates
the opportunity
cost-- the professional
opportunity cost to X--
that the longer we wait to
close a project down that no
longer makes sense, the bigger
the waste of our resources.
But also, think about the
personal opportunity cost
to the people on that team.
When you wake up in
the morning, are you
excited about going into work?
Or do you think, I'd rather
be spending time with my kids,
or sailing a boat
across the Pacific?
When that balance tips, it's
time to beat the inertia
and move on.
Now let's talk about fear.
Killing our own
project is scary.
We're afraid of losing
the respect of our peers.
We're afraid of losing that
promotion or of our job.
Or we're simply
afraid of the unknown,
of what's going to happen next.
I had a really big crash early
on in my career which redefined
my relationship with that fear.
In the late 1990s,
those internet
heydays that Ruth
was talking about,
I was working for a high-flying
management consulting firm.
And I did a lot of
internet case studies,
like for an insurance company.
Should we sell insurance online?
We said yes, they should.
So in 1999, when
all of my friends
went to business school, I
went to a startup instead.
It was called eToys.
As you might guess,
we sold toys online.
I was one of the
first product managers
that they hired in the UK.
So I worked on the UK website.
And then I was the first person
to start eToys in Germany.
So I helped to set
up the company.
I hired the people.
I worked on the website.
In the summer of 2000, our
board back in California
pulled the plug on
our launch a week
before the toys were
coming into the warehouse.
EToys was losing too
much money, too fast,
and expanding to Germany
was not a priority.
So I had to fire all those
people I'd just hired
and had sold on
the internet dream.
I had to fire people
who came to join us
after 20 years of
successful careers in retail
with good pension schemes.
That was really,
really horrible.
And it didn't save eToys.
We went bust just
six months later.
In the European team, we
saw the writing on the wall,
and we let everyone go one
week before Christmas, 2000.
That was horrible, too, firing
people a week before Christmas.
But everyone got paid, and
we closed the company down
in an organized fashion.
In the US, eToys kept going
until the creditors showed up
in the office and
impounded the furniture.
So what I learned
from that is no matter
how bad things get,
even at the worst time,
when you have to close
down your company
and you have to
fire your friends,
it's better to face those facts
earlier, rather than later.
I'm still friends with many
people that were at eToys.
In fact, I saw one of
them just this week.
She now runs a
charity about a cause
that she's really
passionate about.
Many of them have gone on to
do bigger and better things.
So having this experience
so early in my career
made me fearless.
Actually, that's not true.
I'm scared all the time.
I was scared just now,
when I stepped out
in front of all of you.
That's why I have my phone,
so I have my notes in case
I forget what I want to say.
But I've trained myself to
be brave in the face of fear.
And in fact, that's the
definition of bravery.
Bravery is about taking
action in spite of your fears.
When you decide to kill a
project or your company,
that takes, perhaps,
the most bravery.
But we don't have the
opportunity every day.
So how can we train
ourselves to be brave?
Well, it turns out there
are many opportunities
to practice bravery in
our work and in our lives.
So here's my list of
five opportunities
to practice bravery.
Number one.
Jump in.
Try something new.
Even if you have no idea whether
you're going to be good at it.
You all remember the first
day in your first job, right?
When you walked in and you
had no clue what was going on?
I started in consulting.
I don't know what Excel was
until some kind soul showed me.
I did such a jump into
the unknown again,
almost four years ago,
when I came here to X.
I left behind a great role as
director of consumer marketing
in EMEA, in Europe.
I left behind a team I loved,
where I knew everybody.
I left behind a credible
career in marketing.
Even though I've always thought
of myself as a product manager,
I found myself to
be the number 4
on the UK list of top marketers,
just after the CMO of Unilever.
I also left behind the UK, which
had been my home for 20 years,
and uprooted my family
to move to California.
I was excited to
begin a new challenge,
but I was also
really scared to walk
into a team at X that was made
up of scientists and engineers
only.
Neither they nor I knew
what I would be doing,
or whether I would
add any value.
So how did I get over that fear?
Well, I gave myself
a safety net.
I agreed with my new
boss at X, Astro,
that I would come for
six months to try it out.
And I agreed with my old boss
back in Europe, [INAUDIBLE],
to treat it like
a maternity leave.
I would be gone for six months,
and then I would come back,
just like after having a baby.
After three months, I
called her and I said,
I'm not coming back.
And she said, you know,
I kind of suspected
that was going to happen.
But I truly didn't know.
And that's why I
built the safety net.
Number two.
Ask stupid questions and
question assumptions.
I attribute some of my
success in leading teams
to my willingness to always
ask stupid questions.
My team knows this.
In my job, I have to learn
about a new area all the time.
I'm always the person
in the room who
knows the least about an area.
So I ask a lot of questions.
And often I find that there are
other people in the room who
also didn't know
how that worked,
or what the stupid
acronym stood for.
And I found that the experts,
especially the engineers,
are incredibly patient and
love to explain things to you.
[LAUGHTER]
You just have to ask them.
Although I'm not
an engineer myself,
I lead engineering teams.
At first, this was
incredibly intimidating.
How can I be their lead if
I can't be their tech lead?
It turns out that
it's very valuable
to check the assumptions that
have been made by everyone.
Because widely held assumptions
often mask decisions
that haven't actually been made.
And what you'll find out,
if you question them,
is that everyone holds
slightly different assumptions.
Other times, my questions
point to an area
that nobody has thought
about yet at all.
So it turns out that
stupid questions can often
be hard questions,
or helpful questions.
Number three.
Share your work
before it's done.
So Google always had this
"launch early and iterate"
principle.
Gmail was famously
in beta for-- I
think it was about five years.
When Chrome first
launched, many websites
didn't even render
in it properly,
especially banking ones.
At X, we work on hardware, which
takes a long time to get out,
much longer than hardware.
So what we do is we
take our prototypes out
to get them in contact
with the real world
long before they're ready,
long before they're anywhere
near a finished product
in the conventional sense.
Our self-driving
car prototypes have
driven hundreds of millions
of miles on real roads,
testing our hardware
and our software.
And with Google Glass, we ran
perhaps the biggest experiment
of all.
In the Explorer
program we asked people
to test not just the device,
the hardware and the software,
but also to give us feedback
on the use cases, what
it might be useful for.
So from surgeons to chefs,
to parents, to oil engineers,
to fashion models,
people tried it out,
and they gave us feedback--
lots of bad feedback,
some good feedback.
And we learned so much.
The feedback was invaluable.
And in the end, it
led the Glass team
to pivot away from a consumer
product to a device that's
aimed more at the
business market.
Now, it's always better
to get that feedback
earlier rather than later.
And this doesn't just
apply to products.
It applies to anything.
It could be a half-baked idea
that you share with your team.
It could be some
paper wireframes
that you show to your
friends and family.
What matters is
that you don't keep
polishing it and
polishing it until you
feel comfortable sharing it.
You have to still
feel uncomfortable.
Because I guarantee you, if
you wait until it's polished
and you feel comfortable,
it's too late.
Number four.
Stand up for your opinion.
It can be especially
scary if you're
the only person in the room
who has a different view
from everyone else.
Our first use case for
Wing, our Drone project,
was to deliver
defibrillators to people
who just had a heart attack.
Every minute counts
after a heart attack.
So the idea was that
we would get you
the defibrillator faster
than the ambulance can
get there, and thus save lives.
This assumption turned
out to be wrong.
Matt, one of the researchers
in our User Experience team,
put dummies in the lab, and
he got innocent bystanders,
and he gave him
the defibrillator.
And he said, this person's
just had a heart attack.
Save their life.
And he timed how long it
took them to figure out
how to use the defibrillator.
It turns out--
quite a long time.
In fact, about the
same time that it
takes, on average, for
the ambulance to arrive.
And if you do it wrong,
it doesn't work at all.
The trouble was, the team was
in love with this use case.
They loved the idea
of saving lives
by delivering defibrillators.
Some of them had joined
the project because of it.
So Matt had to show the
data and its conclusions
again and again.
In the end, he got help from
Laura, one of my team members,
and they finally convinced the
team to let go of this idea.
So we still think that
delivering stuff with flying
things is a good idea.
But we won't be
delivering defibrillators.
So this brings me back to
killing your own project.
I already mentioned that 97%
of Rapid Eval investigations
get killed.
Earlier this month, we closed
down a project in Foundry
after the team came to
us with the conclusion
that it no longer made
sense to pursue it.
They wrote a really
detailed post-mortem
where they explained why.
They stood up at the
all-hands this week at X
and they explained it to
everyone for half an hour.
And later this year, we hope
to publish their findings
in a peer-reviewed journal.
The important part is this--
I didn't kill that project.
And Rich, who runs Rapid Eval
doesn't kill the Rapid Eval
investigations.
It's always the team.
Because Xers are encouraged
to kill the ideas
and to kill their projects
as soon as it makes
sense to do so-- and
they're rewarded for it.
In Rapid Eval,
they get a sticker
of a crumpled piece of
paper, and they put it
on their laptops as
a badge of honor.
People get applause
from their peers.
They get a spot bonus.
I gave my team that closed down
their own project a spot bonus.
They get promoted because
of it, not despite it.
And they get exciting
new jobs, because as soon
as the project closes
down, every other project
tries to recruit them.
So in other words,
we remove the fear
and we make it safe for people
to kill their own project.
Now let's talk about the
elephant in the room.
Some of you might be thinking,
OK, that's really nice.
You work at X. Um, but
my organization's nothing
like this.
So for those of you who
are running companies
and for those of you who are
running teams in the room,
please, this is your job.
Right?
You have to remove the fear
and remove the inertia.
So please go back and
do that next week.
If you work in a team
where the culture is not
supportive of this kind of
behavior, you have two options.
You can change the culture
from within, or you move on.
In between eToys
and Google, I worked
in brick-and-mortar
retailers for five years,
for a very simple reason.
When eToys went bust in 2001,
how many ecommerce start-ups
do you think got funded?
Not many.
But in retail, I often
felt like an alien that
had landed in another planet.
And in my last job,
just before Google,
the culture in my ecommerce
team was very different
from the rest of the company.
And the physical
manifestation of this
was the fact that we had painted
our walls pink and turquoise
in a fun team event, because
the office was really drab.
Now, this sounds ridiculous.
But it was so radical that the
rumor that the crazy ecommerce
team was painting
their walls spread
throughout the entire
building like a wildfire.
And people kept showing up at
our door with a mug of tea,
on the pretense
that they would just
want to check on something, to
see whether it was really true.
Unfortunately, the
wider organization
remained unchanged.
And in the end, I wasn't
patient enough, not savvy enough
in corporate politics, to
be successful long-term
in that kind of environment.
So I left for Google.
And when I walked
into Google, it
wasn't just the primary
colors of the logo
and the bouncy balls in the
hallway that reminded me
of eToys.
So far, I've talked
mostly about why
it's so important to
teach ourselves bravery
and how to practice it in
our work and in our lives.
But arguably, it's even more
important to teach bravery
to the next generation,
especially our girls.
Reshma Saujani, the
founder of Girls Who Code,
gave the really brilliant
TED Talk a few weeks ago
where she talked about this.
And she talked
about how boys are
taught to climb trees and fall
off and graze their knees,
while girls are taught
to be pretty and perfect.
And she talked about
how in their camps,
the boys have no problem
with sharing imperfect work,
whereas the girls would
rather show a blank screen
than show their attempts
at solving a coding problem
where they feel they've failed.
My daughter is two
years old, and I'm
proud to say that she's
a fearless climber.
I found this out
last summer, when
I was chatting to a
friend in the playground
and not paying attention.
Another parent tapped
me on the shoulder
and said, very disapprovingly,
is that your child
on the top there?
And I turned around to see
her on the top of the big kid
climbing structure.
And the boy on the right is
her eight-year-old brother.
But you see, she's
higher than him.
[LAUGHTER]
I was very scared at this
point, and I ran over.
But then I also felt very
proud, so I took a photo.
[LAUGHTER]
And that, on the right,
is Cosima just last week
at the climbing gym.
She's about 2 meters
up the wall, where
she's running out of boulders.
Because that's how high they
make the kids' climbing wall.
Now, I hope she will always
climb on, all her life.
You are all building
incredible things.
But what I hope
I've done today is
to inspire you to kill
some things along the way.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]